to lebanon now where an armed woman and
a group of activists have stormed a bank
in beirut in a desperate attempt to
access their savings lebanon's banks
have imposed strict limits on
withdrawals pushing many people into
poverty let's bring in al jazeera xena
hoda who's in beirut with the latest
zenith so another hold up in beirut
there was one just a few weeks ago tell
us about what's happened today
in fact in the last hour or so there was
yet another incident so two such
incidents today the third in the past
months you mentioned a female depositor
she stormed the bank behind me with a
group of activists holding a weapon they
poured gasoline they threatened to set
the bank branch on fire if they do not
get access to their savings uh their
money uh the lebanese their money has
been trapped in banks since late 2019
when informal capital controls were
imposed and every time you want to
withdraw money you would draw it at a
rate much lower than the market than the
market value i'll just give you one
example if you want to withdraw 700 they
give you 200 so that's a de facto
haircut so people feel that depositors
feel that they have been uh paying the
price for this financial crisis not the
banks not the state so now they believe
that they want to take their take their
their rights uh by force especially
since this woman's sister is in hospital
suffering from cancer so she said she
needed her money in order to pay a foot
the hospital bill for her sister yeah
and this is their money right this is
what's so astonishing about this it's
their money in their bank accounts how
have people in lebanon been affected by
this economic crisis on a daily
basis this is really a deep economic
crisis it's now in its third year
politicians are not doing anything about
it actually in fact parliament was
supposed to meet today to discuss the
budget the state budget for this year
but there was no quorum and the
parliament is also expected to enact a
number of reforms financial reforms in
order to be eligible for an imf bailout
package this country is in shortage of
dollars the local currency has
depreciated lost more than 90 percent of
its value so people's money really has
become worthless and that's why they
need to access their savings at the same
time the government is nearly bankrupt
it's unable to provide basic services
like electricity water and health care
and this is why
she she really stormed the bank this
morning demanding her money she walked
away with thirteen thousand dollars and
in the second incident the depositor
walked away with thirty thousand dollars
in previous cases they were not detained
for long but maybe authorities might
impose stricter measures simply because
the depositors association is now
warning that there will be more
incidents like this to come thank you
zena zuna roger live in beirut